welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars Ahsoka episode 1 master and
Apprentice yet another Star Wars moment
that makes Qui-Gon Jinn wish he was born
just a few years later for medical
technology to heal stab wounds I am
loving this series so far it's doing
some interesting stuff with Star Wars
lore I got some theories folks my Easter
egg breakdown of episode 2 will come to
this channel tomorrow and me and Tommy's
Wikileaks discussion of episodes one and
two are over on the break room Channel
please subscribe to that channel and the
sagafter has informed us that
entertainment journalists like new
rockstars are allowed to cover movies
and TV shows like this during the strike
but we support these unions in getting a
fair deal from the amdp alright let's
get started we open with a red lucasfilm
logo with some amazing music from
composer Kevin keiner
thank you
Kinder composed all the music for clone
wars and Rebels but often what you heard
on those shows were just light motifs to
John Williams Star Wars themes but in
some rare moments especially in the
later years keiner's true Talent really
came out
[Music]
and here there's this unusual percussion
framing the story of Ahsoka is what I
consider to be a story of Witchcraft and
astrology way more than I expected
whereas normally the lucasfilm Fanfare
has a mix of red and blue lights
flashing over the metallic heads now it
is only the color red we see the mask of
Vader then C-3PO then a clone trooper
helmet could we get a Rex Cameo this
season then the head of an HK assassin
Droid then the helmet of maroc that's
the mysterious new Inquisitor who joins
Balin and shin then huyang then a
stormtrooper then Chopper and then
finally the Mandalorian Night Owl T
visor design of the helmet of Sabine
Wren red is also the color of a new take
on the Star Wars opening crawl which is
incredible it's red instead of yellow
and rather than bending backward into
space it just Scrolls upward so why the
difference why the prominence of the
color red here well I think it's because
we are in a dark era where a new
narrative is being written it's not a
story of ragtag resistors bringing down
an evil Goliath here the good guys start
the story in charge and they are letting
control slip away to the forces of evil
now this opening crawl catches this up
with who Ahsoka is who Morgan ellisbeth
is and who thrawn is now I've made some
other videos about thrawn but he is
awesome come from Timothy zones 1991
heir to the Empire thrawn Trilogy a
character who is brought back into Star
Wars Rebels an animation voiced by Lars
Mickelson who will play the character on
this show he's a blue skinned Kiss An
Imperial Admiral a brilliant individual
we last saw him at the end of rebels
when he and Jedi Ezra Bridger were
zipped out to hyperspace by a pod of per
Gil hyperspace whales and just we're all
clear per Gil p-u-r-r-g-i-l is plural
you don't say per gills just a group of
them is called pergil it's okay we're
all kind of on a learning curve with
this show and remember morganelle Smith
is at bestcar spiritoting woman that
Ahsoka Tano dualed on corbus in the
Mandalorian twitch and with Ahsoka
saying where is Grand Admiral thrawn and
if we have to do this socatano is the
ex-jedi from the Clone Wars animated
series The Apprentice to Anakin
Skywalker who left the Jedi Order after
being wrongfully accused of a Jedi
Temple bombing and she later came back
in Star Wars Rebels as the Rebel agent
code named fulcrum who joined the crew
of the ghost look if this is all new
information to you we are in the middle
of a Rebels recap Series be sure to
watch those okay we see a round hold
ship with New Republic Insignia passing
beneath us not over our heads but
beneath us this vessel is from the mod
calamari Fleet we saw mon calamari ships
like this in Return of the Jedi that's
why the bridge has the same swivel chair
that we saw Admiral Akbar sitting in and
in Rogue one Admiral radd is sitting in
Captain Hale is played by Mark Ralston
who played Drake in Aliens and first
officer Jensen Corbett is played by
Shakira Barrera AKA yo-yo from glow and
the Navigator Droid is voiced by Bonnie
Wilde who worked in the sound department
for the Mandalorian they're early
it isn't home one poem one was Admiral
akbar's Flagship a Return of the Jedi
and apparently continues as a new
Republic's Fleet Flagship to this day
they called it home because mon calamari
converted their aquatic cities into
Starships for the rebel Fleet the
approaching ship is an ATA Class Shuttle
which is significant because these were
used as Jedi Ambassador shuttles during
the Clone Wars it approaches the mon
calamari's ship now with its down facing
Wings framed to look like it is closing
in on this ship with a vice grip the
comms officer reports they're Jedi and I
like how that Astromech droid Turing
said too like wait though this episode
is titled master and Apprentice
referring to these hooded visitors and
yes they do recall Qui-Gon and Obi-Wan
visiting the Trade Federation ship at
the beginning of phantom menace they are
visiting Jedi but there is something off
about them they use Jedi Hardware Jedi
clearance codes but they are not Jedi
since Balin Survived The Purge we
learned later that could explain how he
has all Jedi clearance codes their names
are valence skull and shinhati which is
significant because Skol and hati are
the names of the wolves in Norse
mythology who chased the Sun in the Moon
across the sky in hopes of devouring
them just like these two hunt a star map
a star map blind with loath wolves to
chart their course across the Stars
throughout this video I will be pointing
out the significance of wolf imagery
because I think these names were chosen
by Design Balin is played by the late
Ray Stevenson he passed away earlier
this year and it's super sad because he
is so good on this show that's why this
episode ends with for our friend Rey
Balin skull is an old Jedi who based on
his age would have been a contemporary
with Anakin Skywalker his Apprentice
shinhati has a Padawan Brave telling us
that despite them not being Jedi he does
train her in the Jedi tradition they
carry lightsabers not the color red but
orange it's a sum of a distinction but
it is intentional Dave filoni chose this
to indicate that they aren't Sith who
carry red blades they are something in
between as Shin slashes through these
new Republic officers in the foregrand
you see one poor officer fumbling for
that blaster in his holster the smug New
Republic officers just were not
expecting a fight in the background of
this Hangar you can see New Republic
x-wings and a-wings and they're painted
blue perhaps indicating that the blue
Squadron is back in commission since the
Battle of scared Balin confirms
Jedi ah do you watch Rebels you know
that this line is hugely important to
Ahsoka who had a similar line in her
epic duel with Vader in the season 2
finale
if I will avenge his death revenge is
not the Jedi way I am no Jedi this show
clearly wants us to draw a parallel
between Ahsoka and balen one master who
gave up on her Apprentice because she
saw the nightmare extreme of the Jedi
way one master who thinks that he
actually can do it right but just doing
it his own way with orange Kevin Kinder
uses dramatic piano chords to score
balance Slaughter
[Music]
it's so good and Bala never stops moving
like Vader in the Rogue one kill box
sequence Vader also Incorporated a
levitating Force choke balen even uses
the force to unlock a skomp link which
are normally so complicated only an
astromet can crack them this guy is
clearly mastered the ways of the force
in ways that we haven't seen since Vader
or I guess arguably Luke Skywalker
Morgan elsvet's prisoner jumpsuit is
numbered in orbash 620 and she says
failing you are true to your word
and well paid for it lady Morgan so it
sounds like Morgan set up some
mercenaries to break her out if she were
ever captured okay on to Ahsoka Tano she
explores ruins on a planet that we later
learned it's called Arcana structures
built by Morgan ellsmith's ancestors we
learn the night sisters of dathomir
Morgan elsmith is the nice sister of
dathomir and this is a huge deal the
night sisters refer to a sect of magic
wielding female daphmirians that
included Maul's mother mother thousand
this coven used their green sorcery to
reanimate his legs and the night sisters
are awesome Dave filoni based them on
the witches of death mirror from Dave
wolverton's 1994 Legends novel The
courtship of Princess Leia but the
character the Sorceress charal from the
1985 TV movie Ewoks the Battle of Endor
was later retconned into a night sister
from The Illustrated Star Wars universe
so technically they've been with us for
some time the Legends term was
technically The Witches of death mirror
with Star Wars Clone Wars they were
called the night sisters but they were
considered to be the same thing and then
in 2022 in the book of Boba Fett chapter
3 Danny Trejo's character the rancor
Tamer started talking about the history
of rancors and he said this it said that
the witches of dopamir even rode them
through the forest and fans so making
Morgan ellsbeth a night sister reframes
her character from a samurai inspired
Warrior and military leader that just
supports thrawn into more of a Mystic
figure who practices a different kind of
sorcery than the Jedi or the sithus one
might argue an older form of magic which
is very very interesting for the show
it's going beyond the Jedi and Sith
Legend these Arcana structures were
built by ancient night sisters and three
giant figures with bare feet aligned
with the three inside the temple and
they are all dressed in the same kind of
hooded Garb that we saw mother Towson
wearing these ruins you'll notice are
covered in these Black Sands which at
first I thought might be volcanic soil
but the way it ignites later makes me
think it's kind of a black powder maybe
powdered rhydonium the whole place was
clearly rigged to blow up and keep its
secrets from being found and you'll
notice the sphere she finds is buried in
the same material the night sisters plan
for perhaps this map to never be found
alternatively this substance might be
the ashes of malachor which we see on
malachor in the rebel season 2 finale
they are made of the burnt and
pulverized bones of the Jedi and Sith
who fought there and wiped themselves
out these ashes are inhaled by siths to
imbue the Sith with the dark Essence
trapped within the remains yeah it's
really messed up but it is awesome again
Watch Rebels Ahsoka does this awesome
move of using the force to spin her
lightsabers through the ground around
her and dropping herself on that disc to
the level below and she did the same
move to escape the clone troopers in the
Clone Wars season 7 finale on that
crashing ship on the walls of this
Temple are Engravings and constellations
the three Knight sisters and these
spheres the two are holding one is
levitating and again three of them
mirroring the three witches the weird
sisters of Macbeth which get referenced
in the title of episode 2 toil in
trouble Ahsoka lines up these rotating
pedestals reminding us of like the fifth
element or a puzzle that you'd play in
the Tomb Raider games now if thrawn was
lost in just the past decade why would a
star map to his location be buried in an
ancient Temple thousands of years prior
obviously this map points to a location
thrawn just ended up at thrawn didn't
just go to a where he went to a win I
think and the pathway to that that when
where was lost thousands of years ago in
fact Elizabeth's interest in thron might
have come from thrawn being mentioned in
all night sister bedtime stories that
she grew up with couldn't thrawn end up
being this like 1885 Dr Emmett Brown
figure that all the people in the post
office were taking bets on Ahsoka Rises
to find HK assassin droids waiting for
her remember Morgan Ellsworth used these
on corvus and that Mandalorian episode
but the way that first one was just
frozen and placed the moment Ahsoka
hopped up is so creepy like it was
creeping forward right until it was seen
like you have to keep your eyes on it or
it will Rush at you they fight and these
Droids end up activating these thermal
detonators in their chest just like they
did on corvus and Ahsoka has to run for
it and catches up with her T6 shuttle
piloting it is huyang the mark IV
architect Droid from the Jedi ship The
Crucible who appeared in Clone Wars as a
professor who taught young Jedi about
lightsabers and kyber crystals I love
that Ahsoka somehow tracked him down all
these years after the purge he's voiced
by David Tennant so forgive me if I at
times refer to him as Doctor Who Yang
now real quick we want to say thanks to
Spin Master for sponsoring this video as
well as introduce their new brand 4D
build victory in licensed three Star
Wars puzzles 4D build makes detailed
cardstock 3D Puzzle model kits If You're
a Star Wars Superman who digs puzzles or
wants to add your Museum of Star Wars
collectibles you will love these
everything you need to build a 3D Puzzle
comes in the Box you're not gonna have
to go hunt down a tiny screwdriver or
anything like that each box contains a
set of cardstock puzzle sheets
instructions and a bottle of glue just
in case the instructions are super clear
and easy to follow and in about two to
three hours you can have a finished R2
unit now bigger puzzles take longer but
you know what they say the Death Star
wasn't built in a day destroyed in one
sure but not built there's so much
attention to detail and the puzzles are
super sturdy when they're done they are
designed with replica level detail and
made for showing off which is why every
model comes with a display stand to get
a 4D build Star Wars puzzle model kit of
your own just click the link in the
description below or head to target.com
for as little as 15 you can start your
own Star Wars puzzle collection today I
love the detail of the atmospheric
moisture on the cockpit canopy makes it
all just feel so real Ahsoka reminds
huyang that the Jedi Order does not
exist anymore and huyang asked her how
she got elsewhere to confess the
location of this map let's just say I
didn't follow standard Jedi protocol
yikes sounds like Ahsoka might have
tortured it out of ellsmith perhaps
using that forced torture that kylo Ren
uses in the force awakens they get this
call
ah their call sign is fulcrum which was
ahsoka's Rebel codename during Rebels on
their approach to home one they passed
three x-wings which I'm just gonna
assume are the ones piloted by Trapper
wolf jib Dodger and slash Kidder because
the Cameo Trio de palony Rick family iwa
and Deborah Chao always shows up in
these titles ahsoka's T6 soars past home
one matching the framing of Lando
piloting the Falcon passed home one in
the Battle of endorum Return of the Jedi
inside this Hangar Ahsoka is greeted by
General Harris and Doula the toilet
captain of The Ghost and Rebels here
played by Mary Elizabeth Winstead she
wears a phoenix Squadron patch on her
sleeve as in Rebel season 2 The Ghost
crew joined the Phoenix Squadron and
Hera was promoted to the leader of it
and the back of her jacket shows the
ghost crew Specter 2 patch huyang turns
to look in shock at the teal navigation
protocol Droid that shinhati presumably
sliced we saw this Droid in the opening
scene and as we'll see in episode 2 hu
Yang shares three Po's sense of
mortality they meet in one of the modern
calamari Council rooms that we saw mon
matma giving a briefing in in Return of
the Jedi with the same circular benches
Ahsoka tells Hera that the map contains
the location of thrawn whom herathod
died in the Battle of lothal but Ahsoka
said it was never confirmed if thrawn
survived does that mean Esther yes they
are recapping the finale of rebels when
both Ezra and thrawn disappeared with
the pergol up until this point Hera
thought both of them were dead this mon
calamari officer reports General
the defense controllers requesting an
update on the incident now this is not
Admiral Akbar Admiral Akbar didn't have
this blue color and this officer has a
patch with a single dot on it which
means first officer Lieutenant but this
character does sound like him we should
know that Eric bowersfield passed away
in 2016. okay onto the planet lothal the
recurring setting of the rebels series
we see Governor writer Azadi given a
speech writer Azadi was a prisoner on
lothal in season two but broke out who
knew Ezra's parents and joined the rebel
cause he was voiced by Clancy Brown who
plays him in live action here also on
this Deus Senator Jai Kell another
character from Rebels the cadet in the
local Imperial Academy alongside Ezra
Bridger hell was believed to be more
sensitive Vinnie Thomas plays him here
but the animated version was voiced by
Rubio actor Dante Bosco they're standing
in front of this commemorative mural we
saw this in the final scene of Rebels
Sabine Wren painted it she's quite the
artist and it is the same exact 2D
illustration it depicts the whole ghost
crew Hera Sabine Ezra kananjaris Zeb and
Chopper both cats and we see two loath
wolves two of them one light one dark
could this mirror Skol and hati as the
Wolves of Norse mythology are they in a
way fighting on the same side of the
ghost's crew so writer asks jaikel where
is she actually I think you can't see
sabine's Speeder bike in the lower right
in the far distance in the background on
the ground there okay said to some rock
music that is definitely not common for
Star Wars Sabine Wren played by Natasha
Leo bordizo speeds down the slothal
highway she's wearing this helmet with
some low-cat drawings and the orbish
letters of b a e and b or babe she also
has a phoenix Squadron patch on her
jacket though later in her box in her
home there is another Phoenix Squadron
patch which I wonder might be Ezra's
meanwhile the orabesh on the traffic
overhangs reads caution and then later
sector 7 Sabine is chased by two e-wings
now previously these only showed up in
Legends literature first introduced in
the dark Empire Comic they were known as
escort shuttles introduced during
thrawn's campaign to rebuild the Fallen
Empire Sabine seems to have a familiar
relationship with this pilot and notices
call sign is Specter 2-1 so Specter was
how the crew of the ghosts numbered
themselves Sabine with Specter 5 Kanan
Jairus with Specter 1 Harrison Doula
with Specter 2 Chopper Specter 3 Zeb was
Specter four Ezra with Specter 6 and
then later on Hera and kanan's son Jason
was Specter seven so it seems like
they've continued that tradition with
all the lothal pilots the astromic Droid
that shorts out is actually based on the
vintage R2D2 toy from Kenner with the
teardrop indents for the red and the
blue eyepieces really really fun Easter
egg there Sabine lives in a
communication tower that looks like
Ezra's Roost lothalnet com Tower e272
seems like she's just moved into the
home that he started the series in on
the walls she's painted several
Stormtrooper helmets that have been xed
out you can also see some drawings of
loathe cats loath wolves Chopper and
some stacked Stones it might be an
outdoor Jedi training of having to stack
Stones like Yoda did with Luke on
dagobot and we learned that she is kept
as a pet my favorite character in this
series this spotted loaf cat which looks
like a mix of VFX in the white shots but
in close-ups a practical puppet which is
similar to the mix of VFX and puppetry
that brought grogu to life just like
grogu I want one of these things low
cat's a reminder are native to lothal we
actually saw one in live action growling
at grogu in the Mandalorian as the bean
feeds this furball in the foreground
under the table collecting dust is her
old Mandalorian helmet Sabine came from
the Mandalorian house visla and served
as an imperial Weapon Specialist before
she defected but her family on Cronus
remained loyal to the Empire she briefly
wielded the dark saber she got trained
by Kanan in season three but she handed
off the dark saber to bocaton crease
Sabine had always kept her hair short
because her scalp would get hot Under
The Helmet so the fact that her hair is
grown out now tells us that she's left
that Warrior light behind she plays a
holly recording from Ezra Bridger who is
played in the series by Iman espandi
sorry for disappearing on you as a Jedi
sometimes you have to make the decision
no one else can we're not really family
but you're like a sister to me I know
your fight isn't over
and now I won't be there to help you
and I'm counting on you to see this
through oh wow so like Tony Stark in
Avengers end game Ezra Bridger knew what
he was about to do make a sacrifice play
with Ron in the pergol and he took a
moment to make a goodbye recording
before that final fight I like the
detail how he rubs his head when he says
we're not really family because that was
just recurring thing in Rebels all these
members of the ghost crew had their own
families that they were either running
away from or dying to get back to yet
they still loved each other and clearly
Ezra doesn't want to insert himself in
between Sabine and her family Morgan
Elizabeth tells Shin that she's the
night sister of deathmere you're a witch
damn so Elizabeth rejects the pejorative
of someone who would use sorcery for
whims instead reframes the idea of being
a night sister as a Believer who holds
closer Dogma in order to survive over
the ages someone who has survived in the
way that the Jedi and the Sith have not
survived Shin still doesn't trust it
though what threat is she spending no
it's not witchcraft yes Elizabeth is
obsessed with the idea of fate and
prophecy and spinning thread comes from
the Greek archetype of spiders and the
fates spinning thread and weaving the
tapestry of the future but Balin noticed
no longer sees it as a bogus
Superstition but with bailin is an
Inquisitor who we still know little
about maroc their helmet is similar to
that of the eighth brother in the rebels
season 2 finale that character
supposedly died before reminder that
inquisitors are Jedi Hunters recruited
by Darth Vader and Palpatine after The
Purge all the former Jedi to hunt down
all the other Jedi refugees that are
still in hiding we know this one's an
Inquisitor because all inquisitors carry
this round hilted lightsaber that spins
like this Sabine dreams about Ezra and
we hear his voice saying
and if you look closely in the corner of
this room behind her are some store
that's including a few scout trooper
helmets they kind of look like the one
Zeb stole for Ezra from that scout
trooper who jumped on board the ghost
sorry they also wore some scout trooper
helmets when they first went into the
Jedi Temple on lothal there's just a lot
of different instances that they would
have these from this shot of Sabine
looking out from the comms Tower and the
two x-wings and ahsoka's T6 mirrors the
opening shot of Ezra in Rebels season 1
episode 1 when he looked out at the Star
Destroyer that arrived to lothal Ryder
Azadi scold Sabine we're missed sipping
everyone was there
not everyone yes Sabine
right without his
recliner doesn't sell John Williams
themes
exvoke it like he did here
[Music]
Sabine re-enters the T6 and Kevin kainer
includes some sweet flute and clarinet
and Bell Chimes which really is just
some classic John Williams tones that
you hear in movies like E.T her bunk
includes drawings of more loaf cats and
Chopper some stacked stones and some Tie
fighters Rebels ended with Ahsoka
rejoining Sabine to go off in search of
Ezra Bridger but now it's a play that
Ahsoka tat Sabine and the Jedi ways and
it didn't go too well you never made
things easy for me
Master there is nothing easy about being
a Jedi yeah Ahsoka knows this quite well
all her Jedi relationships ended in
tragedy so Sabine steals the map and
gets tracked by Shin's Pro Droid
reminding us of maul tracking Qui-Gon
and Phantom Menace meanwhile Hera tells
Ahsoka
you won't do it difficult at times
Anakin never got to finish my training
for the end of the Clone Wars I walked
away from him and the Jedi the framing
of this shot with Harris projection
behind ahsoka's shoulder mirrors the
framing of Ahsoka in the lothal Jedi
Temple and rebel season 2 episode 18
when Anakin's ghostly form appeared over
that same shoulder and turned into Vader
and finally here she began to come to
terms with the fact that her parting
ways of the Anakin was followed almost
immediately by Anakin's fall to the dark
side and that is guilt She carries with
her to this day Sabine inspects the map
sphere and deduces that the three witch
statues align with this three-pronged
symbol realizing that the map's key is
contained within it and uses this
Rubik's Cube twisting of its different
faces to realign it and activate it so
again significance of the number three
three witches three faces three is the
witch's number it's also the number of
the Divine Trinity in the Star Wars
mythology of the Father the daughter and
the son of mortis with this map decoded
IT projects around the sphere the Galaxy
they are currently in with a path to
another galaxy episode 2 explores this
path to Purity a bit more and I'll get
more into it in tomorrow's breakdown but
just to tease my theory I think this map
was built by the word cotton Invaders an
ancient civilization bar pre-dating the
Jedi in the Sith something explored and
Knights of the Old Republic with star
maps in that game and the path the Pergo
could lead back through time to the
reconnaissance I would roll my eyes to
this Theory but the lucasfilm team
inserted our cotton Easter egg in Andor
Andor of all things they want us to
think about the ricotta Invaders Sabine
gets attacked by these HK droids they
steal the map they blast her she
runs into shinhati and she ignites the
green lightsaber of Ezra Bridger Sabine
even starts patiently standing at the
ready position just as to do
with the darksaber but Shin is more
patient she lets Sabine charge first big
mistake Sabine notice has Sabine uses
these desperate overhead chopping
motions leaving herself vulnerable and
she tries to rush to the end of the
fight with just one power blow
um I mean to be fair this is being this
is the first time she's picked up a
lightsaber in years and shin we just saw
at the beginning of this episode got a
whole warm-up round of New Republic
officers with Clumsy trigger fingers and
throughout this fight notice how Shin
fights a bean closer and closer and
closer to the ground until she stabs her
through the side I guess missing vital
organs because even after the steps of
being continued slashing which I guess
is the show's way of saying nah she's
okay she'll bounce back but either way
this Apprentice lost the battle of
apprentices because on the good side the
master and Apprentice are still separate
and they're facing a master and
Apprentice who have had a lot more time
together trust in each other so I love
these closing credits they show golden
lines on a star map this is the path to
paridia that gets talked about in
episode two it's passing through
constellations and words in an ancient
language they pass a loath wolf and a
ring of Pergo hyperspace whales and
notice how all the different lines beam
back to one destination this is likely
where thrawn is and where Ezra is
remember the loath wolves and Rebels LED
Ezra into the world Between Worlds that
is a realm between points in time it's
the closest Star Wars has ever gotten to
time travel yes it's crazy but based off
of these first two episodes it seems
like we might be going there the pergol
could operate on a bridge that takes us
through hyperspace through time and the
reason this path leads to thrawn
seemingly in one destination it's not
because thrawn just hasn't ever gotten
up from his chair wherever he is it's
because that destination doesn't lead to
a place it leads to a win more on this
in tomorrow's breakdown of episode 2. I
want to thank Noah Chan for his research
help with this breakdown and again
please check out our Rebels re-watch
series for more context on all of these
characters you can follow me on all
social platforms at eavos follow me
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you